[Music]
the raiders were back in action against
an old afc west
rival this afternoon the raiders and the
chargers did not disappoint
john treach begins our silver and black
coverage tonight john
for 60 years the raiders and chargers
have taken turns ripping each other's
heart out there is mutual
love and that they love seeing each
other walk off the field defeated
there have been last minute touchdowns
suspenseful comebacks and today a
dramatic defensive stop in hollywood
worthy of a sequel two schools of mask
wearing the welding
shield in the face wrap the raiders were
in your face with
the running game all 60 minutes devonte
booker behind a cavalry of
massive offensive lineman turbo boosted
into the end zone for the score
it's 7-0 that testosterone just
overflowing in the running back room how
about josh jacobs
the pro bowler jolted by a huge alec
engel block making it
14-7 now here comes second half
nelson aguilar alert derek carr with a
nelson seeking
missile touchdown raiders 43 yards in
the air then back to just conventional
pass and catch in the back of the end
zone
that one to darren waller 28-17 las
vegas as a field goal chargers
one drive to win it is
caught or so they thought in fact the
ball
was grabbed by donald parham the tight
end but
it hits the ground it is incomplete and
just like that
the chargers lose at the buzzer 31-26
on an unforgettable day in l.a now there
are fun games to cover and then there
are classics with unfathomable finishes
kevin martin can say she saw that
firsthand kevin
what a day in the afc west good evening
yes a huge win for the raiders you know
what john there's actually been some
all-time classics between these two
teams throughout the years but this one
definitely has to rank up here as the
raiders survive and walk away with the
31-26
win and afterwards head coach john
gruden spoke about the emotions
running onto the field after this win
i mean you can only imagine it's it's
what you you're in this business for
it's why fans love it it's it's really
what makes the world go around you know
the the competition
and the excitement uh the thrill of
victory and the agony of defeat and that
that pretty much summarizes it i wish
uh jim mckay was here to say it for me
and not only was it an exciting win but
it was a great team win if you look down
the stats i mean
all across the board offensively almost
every raider contributed you saw darren
waller catch a touchdown nelson aguilar
catch a touchdown devonta booker
and josh jacobs each ran in for a
touchdown it was an all-around team win
the raiders have to be ecstatic about
this one as they head back to vegas
and get ready for another afc west
opponent the broncos